faites-vous la machinerie ali abu
suivante en cours moi ça fait milan je
suis là je fais la vaisselle je fais les
distractions n'y a pas de radio il n'y a
pas de télévision y alors elles ont
inventé un jeu alors on fait un top à je
suis parfois lorsque tu fais de toi pas
michel sardou alors j'ai pas encore la
musique j'ai les paroles c'est dément je
voulais chanter non jeu j'essaye
d'apprendre on s'amuse avec ses folles
alors sur la terre voilà ça commence
comme ça en ce temps là monsieur le
surveillant des classes secondaires
étaient un peu efféminé sont bizarres
sur la tête
en ce temps-là je lisais le grand mont
né après les lumières je me faisais
plaisir je me faisais dormi oui je
m'inventais un monde rempli de femmes
aux cheveux roux c'est curieux aux
cheveux roux parce que c'est pas gentil
pour mireille darc pages dont il
prendrait la forêt me fournir une
matière en farine c'est un enfant qui
parle avec les jets 10 de femmes pas de
jeunes filles n'aiment pas les jeunes
chine cette année là je n'oublierai
jamais le regard de vipère que m'avait
lancé ce vieux rat une pas l'école
cette année là j'allais poser les yeux
sur la croupe incendiaires de ma
professeure de droit à oui je m'étonne
pas elle avait mis le feu en moi j'avais
avalé la lumière j'aurais aimé la terre
entière ça c'est beau seulement les
femmes pas les jeunes finissent à lui
revient pauvre de moi monsieur le
surveillant les classes secondaires
passer ses nuits à espionner du couloir
des secondes au dortoir des premières
comment les jeunes étaient couchés bien
sûr le dos les bras croisés sur la
couverture de laine des fois qu'on
aurait décidé s'est enfin passé
retards et pauvres chimère c'est
pourtant là que durant des années j'ai
rêvé d'adultère que je n'ai jamais
consommé et chaque nuit quand je tiens
dans mes bras
chaque ennemi conjonction d'un mais ils
se croisent exagère sur la terre est
plein de buts à midi si on est très fier
d'avoir fait trop belle n'en fait rien
ah non vous les regardez à droite aussi
aux non non pas du tout alors je dis oui
c'est ça une femme trop fia qui se
refuse à me donner un peu plus plus
nécessaire parce que j'hésite à le
défaire de son carcan de préjuger de ses
très beaux parce que je n'ai pas la
manière j'ai presque envie de lui
confier qu en ce temps là j'avais un
surveillant les classes secondaires mais
ça la frairie c'est une chanson triste
unes aux autres et aux petits mais je
n'ai pas l'argent je vais pas voir la
chanter je vais la prendre